foreign
I discovered that he was putting the
money aside and it was the large amount
of money like forty thousand dollars it
sounds like
you all need a control alt delete on how
you all communicate with one another and
how you'll handle money inside your own
house
[Music]
what is going on this is John with the
Dr John deloney show so grateful that
you've joined us
this is book launch week for building a
non-anxious life
it's a book that com it just follows
this show it completely reimagines hey
what if your body is not a train wreck
what if you're not broken what if your
body's actually working exactly as it
should in the world we've created is
insane it makes no sense for our bodies
what if that's the case
so check it out go to John deloney.com
building a non-anxious life this is the
week
um and let me just give you some like
behind the scenes stuff
um the reason this is important for
pre-sale and for that first week is all
of pre-sale and that first week of sales
adds up to your week one sales and
that's what decides whether you make the
best seller list or not and it just
helps escalate the conversation about
the book so if you're thinking about it
thinking about it thinking about it go
grab it anywhere books are sold it's in
all the stores it's on the Internet it's
at johnoloon.com Amazon it's everywhere
but go check it out and if you're just
now joining us we have had a run of the
largest
um influx of people ever
um it just feels like the 17 finally did
your jobs the original 17 listeners and
um man we are getting
thousands and thousands of thousands of
new listeners if you are new we're so
grateful you're here the show is about
mental health emotional health
relationships how to be well uh
parenting schools everything you can
think of what's going on in your job all
of the things that affect us on the
day-to-day basis and I spent 20 years
sitting with people when the wheels have
fallen off when they don't know what to
do next and so my promise is I'm going
to sit with you and we're gonna figure
out what do we do next what's your next
right move because life comes at us hard
and it comes at us fast and it is all
over the place so if you want to be on
this show it's real people going through
real problems go to John deloney.com ask
ask or go to one call call
1-844-693-3291 leave a message and we
will hollaback girl at you I ain't no
hollaback girl ah you probably are all
right let's go out to Robbie and welcome
to Miami Florida what's up Robbie
excited to talk to you today I am more
excited to talk to you what's up
um so my question is
how
can
um trust be
um restored and if if it's that possible
and how can we do it
what happened
um so I've been married for eight years
and when we had our son in 2019
um
everything was kind of you know slowing
down because of the pandemic right
and my husband
he he led me to believe that we were
going through some financial problems
and stuff like that so hey Robbie talk
directly into the phone for me okay
yes there you go perfect okay so
um your husband was leading you to
believe that y'all are going through
some significant financial difficulties
yes okay and then
so I picked up extra jobs extra shifts
and I was like you know doing everything
I could to help and everything I got
from you know from those jobs I would
give it to him to help pay bills and
everything
and then a couple years after I
discovered that he was putting the money
aside
and it was a large amount of money
oh like forty thousand dollars to see so
he told you hey we're broke we need I
need you I need you to get on the horn
so you have this newborn and you go get
one job two job three jobs and you're
working like crazy is he working like
crazy too
okay so y'all are working working and
you think y'all are just treading water
turns out he has a secret account with
forty thousand dollars in cashing
yes what was he doing with that money
um well he said he was just saving it
for you know for
uh emergencies and everything but I did
I had no idea about this money or the
account okay I had no access to it so
kind of seemed um Shady to me yep
and okay so we talked through it and
then uh we used the money to put down on
uh a down payment on a house for us
and then
a few years later
um he's doing it again
um
so I kind of what is it about your home
that you don't know on a week to week
month-to-month basis
what the your financial situation is
what the bills are and how much money is
coming in like I'm trying to think how I
could pull this off with my wife and I
couldn't because
we share a checking account
and
we talk on a regular basis about how
much money my paycheck is going to be I
work on commission so how much money is
how many books we sell right how many
speaking gigs I got so
um we I know and then the electric bill
comes and then the water bill we don't
have water bill because we live out in
the in the on the moon but
we've got all these bills insurances and
things so I'm wondering with you how
would you not know or have some context
if you come to you and says we're broke
we're broke wouldn't you know like
yeah I I didn't care much you know
because he used to handle all finances
and
um I work part-time and use whatever I
got to you know take the kids for a fun
day or something like that so I never
worried about too much because I never
thought you know this would happen
and
um now I'm more cautious of it and
because of it too everything that he
does things a bit Shady to me
yeah but hold on
[Music]
this is gonna sound strange but I'm
gonna kind of defend him a little bit
and I'm only defending him because he's
not on the phone if he was on the phone
I'd be having words with him but he's
not here okay yeah you don't participate
and in fact you keep your money
you have your job he has his job I'm
assuming his job pays for all the bills
of the house takes care of everything in
your part-time job just was fun money
for you and the kids
no I hope at the home too okay all right
so you're putting it in the central pot
also but yeah by your own words you're
not involved you're not participating
you're just putting money into an
account
and he says I got it and you're like
great I don't want to deal with it I
don't think about it
and so when he decides to handle it how
he wants to handle it because he's on
his own out there
and in fact most of the time people call
this show their husband has spent forty
thousand dollars gambling or on escorts
or something not putting into an account
as a giant emergency fund for the family
so I'm not going to say what he did was
right and he did it without you knowing
and maybe he said we're broke because he
has a goal of fifty thousand dollars
because he wants to get us out of a get
y'all house and so it sounds like
you all need a control alt delete on how
you all communicate with one another and
how you'll handle money inside your own
house
okay there's
okay
you're not originally from the US we're
all born in
um South America okay
and
um this money it was not in account here
so it was an account in his country that
our country that only him and his mom
had access to it maybe that's why
that was a big problem for me yeah so is
he sending money home yes I know that's
a huge uh I mean that's a super super
common thing that people come to the
states and then send a ton of money home
he just did it without talking to you
yes exactly
so
let me ask you this and this is a hard
question again he's not on the phone
only you are so I'm asking you I don't
understand like I'm picking on you but
you're the only one here
no yeah I understand if he was to calm
down and sit with you and say
I feel a deep obligation in my soul to
help take care of my mom
or honey I'm scared
bills are piling up I'm hearing about
this thing called covet I'm hearing
about this thing called inflation I
don't understand
um
I need us to have a season where you go
work two or three jobs and I know you're
going to miss the baby but we need this
I'm gonna put in overtime
how would you respond to that
would you say oh absolutely I'm 100 in
on our marriage and on what we're
building here in the states or would you
say uh-uh I'm not doing any of that
I don't know I will be completely on
board okay 100 okay
okay so the reason I'm asking that is
sometimes if our partner's not safe if
the person that we're doing life with
isn't safe
whether that's with Secrets whether
that's with fears whether that's with
money whether that's with whatever
um it's common that we create another
world just to exist right we have to
carve a little bubble of safety out in
our in our lives that doesn't sound like
that's happening here so can you rebuild
trust one thousand percent yes
okay but
you cannot do it without two thing two
key ingredients for rebuilding trust
number one everybody has to come to the
exact same table and put everything out
on the table
all these secret accounts all of your
wants and needs he's going to say I need
to take care of my mom and you're going
to say I want you and me to build a life
in the states right you have to put all
of that stuff on the table
the second thing is if you say the
person who um feels deceived my husband
told us we were broke he actually was
secretly saving money so we could buy a
house secretly saving money so we could
be safe
the per but he didn't tell you and he
may have lied to you about it or hinted
around it and he was also giving money
to his mom without telling you whatever
we call that Financial infidelity okay
so let's say he cheats on you with money
and if you choose to stay
the second thing is you cannot continue
to beat him up every day of the week
moving forward if you choose to stay you
choose to go all in again also
yeah yeah I definitely I don't do that I
um I understand
it's um
it's just I don't feel like
you know I completely trust him uh-huh
absolutely but have you sat down and
said here's what I need to trust you I
need access to all the accounts I needed
an accounting for all of our money on a
weekly basis on a budget meeting every
week okay is he doing that
uh sometimes he tries to get out of here
but yeah okay most of the time this type
of issue is not money related
this type of issues other things are
going on too
okay
is that true about your marriage or is
your marriage perfect other than the
fact that he's secretly saving money
without telling you where it is oh
oh that's right usually this sort of
divide this sort of disagreement on how
we're going to be a steward of the
resources that we have it sounds like
you'll both work your butts off y'all
are both hard workers right yes and you
both love your you both love your baby
yes we have two kids okay but is he a
good dad
yeah
um
sounds like you'll need to sit down and
say who do we want to be and what do we
want this to look like
okay
um
if I gave you two tickets to the money
and marriage event that me and Rachel
Cruz are putting on here in Nashville
which I'll be able to make it up here
um there's 799 tickets I'll give you two
one for you and one for your husband if
you all want to come
it's a weekend it's a weekend marriage
retreat
that's awesome yeah you have to find
someone to keep your kids and it's in
October you can stay on the line and
Jenna will get you hooked up with the
details it's October 23 I think that
weekend if I'm not mistaken
um but we have a few tables left and
I'll give you one of them and it would
be a whole weekend how to learn to come
together as a couple or talk about sex
and intimacy and all that we're also
going to talk about how to handle your
money and how to handle your money
together and how to dream about what you
want your life to look like and reverse
engineer that into the present and build
it Forward would you be into that
oh yeah that's awesome thank you so much
all right so hang on the line I'm gonna
hook you up with those two tickets if
you're not gonna come though let us know
because those tickets are really
valuable
um they are selling out real fast and so
if you're not going to be able to make
it up here I understand coming from
Miami to Nashville that's a that's a big
commitment both in travel and in getting
child care and stuff but if y'all want
to come I'd love you to be my guest and
we'll we'll at least give you all the
tools to put all of these questions on
the table that y'all are going to
address
but for everybody else listen if you
want to rebuild trust number one
everything's got to be on the table all
the secrets the second thing is if y'all
choose to stay you choose to work hard
to rebuild the trust and I'm going to
add a third one you both have to be very
clear about what you need to help
rebuild Trust
that's it
those three things have to happen if you
want to rebuild trust and then it's just
going to take time there's going to be
ups and downs two steps forwards five
steps back he's gonna have a glance
she's gonna turn over her cell phone
he's gonna put some money in the thing
he's gonna give money at his local it's
just it's just it's a it's a thing y'all
gonna do together as you grow together
can you rebuild trust absolutely
absolutely yes we'll be right back
hey good folks deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time those become healthy habits
they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallo
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
Hollow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hallow.com deloney today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hollow.com deloney for 90
days free
all right let's go out to Richmond
Virginia and talk to an aluminum
baseball bat Easton what's up Easton
hey John what's up good to talk to you
man I am Starstruck right now I don't
know about you I'm dude I don't get to
talk to somebody named after baseball
bats very often Easton so it's good
great to talk to you it's fantastic
what's up man it's an honor thank you
thank you uh so first I want to say um
and this turns into
um that you
you you and your show played a huge role
in uh saving my marriage after
infidelity and and helping my wife and I
build it into something completely new
and so much better
um so I really want to thank you thank
you for that we uh we're actually coming
down to uh to Nashville in October to
come see uh are you coming marriage
getaways that's fantastic yeah so this
show is turning into a big uh marriage
Retreat commercial that's that's awesome
I'm glad you're coming dude
um I think it'll be sold out by the time
this uh podcast airs but um dude that's
fantastic we can't wait to see you it's
gonna be a blast
thanks yeah we're we're stoked very cool
man so what's up man how can I help all
right so the big question I've got for
you today is how
do I start loving myself
um and then I've got got some context if
you want as well go for it
all right so I thought that because I'm
super nervous I'll bring it that's good
so as long as I can remember I haven't
really liked myself uh for a long time I
hated myself I was I was the fat kid in
school I was awkward I felt like I
couldn't do anything right that kind of
stuff
um and I I worked on really avoiding
that and just kind of ignoring the the
voices in my head telling me I wasn't
good enough but when my wife was
unfaithful
um it really brought those voices back
to the Forefront and uh they've they've
just been screaming at me ever since
um I've gotten really good at kind of
logicing my way out of it that all right
that's probably not true but it's it's
been really hard for me to really
believe that I guess in my heart and so
I'm at a point now where I don't hate
myself I know I'm not terrible but I
cannot fathom loving myself and I just
don't even know where to start with that
um and that's why I called in today dude
that's awesome
um I think by the time this airs
um it will I will have
I've been doing a ton of media lately so
I don't remember which if I've said this
on this show but I'll go ahead and say
it here
um
and this is me being as open as I can
too okay
um
we did a study a while ago we did a
survey and asked a lot of our audience
you know what's your favorite things
about the show what do you not like Etc
one of the very top things that people
don't like about this show
they get frustrated with is I'm always
telling people that you're worth being
loved and you have to start any sort of
lifestyle transformation from a place of
I care about myself enough to go be a
steward of my money my body my
relationships whatever and their Chief
complaint was that I talked to myself so
badly on the show I'm always making
jokes about John always laughing about
this and that so I tell you that to tell
you
about six or seven months ago not very
long ago
um I was meeting with a therapist and
she asked me to make a fist
and put it in my chest and say the words
I love this guy
and dude I couldn't do it
at first it was funny I was like ah
stupid did you just do it
and I was like no come on
now this is somebody who I have told
things I've never told anyone on planet
Earth ever
and she said I'm gonna sit here and wait
and so I put my hand in my chest and I
smiled but it wasn't a happy smile it
was I'm smiling so hard to keep from
sobbing I can't say those words and she
said that's where you're gonna start she
said as cheesy as this sounds you're
gonna look in the mirror and start
practicing saying the words I love this
guy
and
that's where I started
okay so that's number one it's got to be
something you practice and I know it
sounds insane but you got to practice it
Okay so that's your homework assignment
even if you have to fake it act like
you're a theater major and you're doing
a performance that's fine
underneath that performative like just
saying the words I love this guy
um
you said something really important that
I want you to hang on to you said voices
all say alarms but there's something
really remarkable about the human mind
in that when it sounds the alarms or it
starts speaking up stories and voices in
our heads
and it's trying to get us away from
something it's scared of like a bunch of
kids calling you fatso
or a bunch of uh teachers telling you
that your grades aren't good enough or a
mom and dad saying don't say that or
you're gonna make your dad mad and or do
don't do that again young man because
your mom gets really pissed off when you
do that and you learn at seven years old
that it's your job to make sure Mom and
Dad are okay
when that happens
um and you avoid those situations
your body wins because it stayed alive
and avoided them and what does it do it
reinforces those voices it makes the
alarms louder and louder and louder
and so in your case the only way through
this
is through it
on a foundation of a bunch of little
bitty winds
so give me an example of something you
don't like about you
what is something that you feel is
unlovable
uh first thing that comes to mind is to
struggle with my whole life is
definitely my body okay my weight
against what standard
I I guess just you know seeing it seeing
other people even just like normal
people in the street not even just like
movie stars or something just
I know like man they look good in those
clothes and that's pretty cool and I
wish I could and I I don't I couldn't I
wouldn't
I don't I couldn't I wouldn't aren't
true statements
so what is are you overweight
I am okay how much so
um maybe 30 pounds or so and I so after
high school I worked real hard
um you know I lost like 60 pounds and I
was back at a healthy weight and just
since you know over the past 10 years or
so it's just been taken back up yeah so
let's go with uh yeah that makes sense
because my guess is right after high
school you worked out really hard
because you hated that you didn't look
good
yeah and you went to the gym every day
to show because you hated your body
yep and that is simply not sustainable
my friend Sal de Stefano has uh he told
me that in a private conversation
and the reason I ask up against what
standard is because I've struggled with
body dysmorphia my whole life
and
um
I'm comparing myself to whatever the
next standard is whatever line I cross
like I look good now I'm always on to
well it's not Brad Pitt you know I mean
it's like as soon as you pass Brad
Pitt's like well I'm not that model and
for you it's not a hundred pounds it's
not 60 pounds well I'm 30 pounds
and when you play that game it the line
will always move my promise to you is if
you lost 40 pounds tomorrow morning and
you woke up with a six-pack abs you the
line would move on you because you
hadn't dealt with the underlying thing
until you can get to a place where you
say I love Easton so I'm gonna take care
of Easton
I love myself enough
to go give myself an hour every morning
of walking I love myself enough I I'm
just gonna pass on the donuts
do you see how different that is that's
a lifetime that's sustainable
yeah that's how parents work 12 hours a
day seven days a week because they love
their kids it's for something it's not
against something so
um so you're overweight and with that
comes all the shame of I should be
working out I should be not eating this
I look terrible and then your wife goes
and cheats on you and it just confirms
every one of those gnarly stories you've
been telling yourself for years right
yep tell me how that went
uh
it was it was interesting she I didn't
like Discover it or anything she uh she
had the courage to tell me
um and uh luckily we're both big fans of
shows and so
um I heard you know a bunch of episodes
about people talking about you know
being cheaters and kind of What It's
Like on that side and so
worked real hard to have love and
patience and Grace for her and she
really appreciated that and so
um I think I started looking at two
is she made a decision and she made
mistakes
um but it wasn't uh I guess wasn't by
herself I kind of played a role in
creating a an environment that
maybe made those mistakes easier to make
uh I was I was working too much and even
when I wasn't at work I was I was at
work in my head
um
so there was a there was a lot of guilt
there and so that paired with
uh the alarms of the voice is telling me
oh yeah of course she did because you're
not worth
you're not worth loving
sorry oh you're good man
it was easier to to say I forgive you
because it it was just me like it didn't
matter if I was hurt did you ever get
enraged
like
a couple times not for long hold on hold
on you need to spend some time being
really really angry
let me be super clear you did not
deserve to be cheated on man
I don't care how overweight you are
I don't care how much you work to
provide for your wife and your family
I don't care how much of an addict you
are
to busyness
you didn't deserve to be cheated on and
I'm all dude I'm all about Grace and
forgiveness and let's figure it out I've
been married 21 years man
I am a only here because my wife is
somebody who believes in Grace and
forgiveness and let's try again let's
try again
but you didn't deserve this man
nobody deserves to have their soul
ripped out like that
my fear for you is
you went yeah that makes sense I can see
that because I'm such a piece of crap
and that's not true
it's almost as though the person most
invested in taking care of you and
defending you it's just kind of given up
on you and that's you
what's the origin story of that
who told you you weren't worth fighting
for
I guess I just been hearing it
I'm not you know not in those exact
words but most of my life you know kids
at school weren't terrible they were
kids but uh growing up stop you keep
blowing it off
listen brother my closest friends on the
planet
my bestest bestest friends for years
40-year plus friendships
used to tackle me when we were in grade
school
and they would have a little sticks and
pine needles and they would poke on all
my zits because I had bad acne
and to this day
I struggle with that and dude we were
kids they were my friends we were
playing I made fun of them because they
were little they made fun of me because
I was humongous I made fun of them
because of X they made fun of me because
I had zits and to this day so you can't
tell me like ah they're just kids that
stuff still hurts and it stays with you
forever right
until you finally are honest with
yourself about how much you were hurt
you're going to continue having to build
these little duct tape Bridges these
duct tape lily pads for you to walk over
the swamp that is your life
I think it would be good for you to
spend some time being honest my mom said
this and that sucked
she shouldn't have said that
my dad used to say this and this and he
would hit me here and do this that was
the worst
my mom treated my dad so bad
or my dad's been all you have to be
honest those kids said these things man
and they are still in there
can you do that I feel like I'm getting
worked up in your behalf I care about
you feeling bad I think more than you do
I think so
have you have you heard of the Learned
helplessness experiment they did with
the dogs
yeah yeah actually that's you
for those of you who don't know what I'm
talking about there's an experiment done
where they had
um
I'm gonna butcher it but they had a a
they put dogs in a cage and the floor
was delivered electric shocks and
in short order if there was no way for
the dogs to get out
the dogs just sat there and took it even
when they provided a way for the dogs to
get out and move to another part of that
cage where
um there was no electric shock the dogs
just sat in it
they just sat in it they they just got
shocked and shocked and shocked
the other part of the experiment was
when they would turn it on and they
would have other it would be
intermittent the dogs learned all right
I can get out of this I can get out of
this I'm gonna keep fighting I can keep
moving
and you just learned to sit there and
take electric shocks brother
and so let me flip this whole thing
around
what is something that you do better
than anybody else and don't say nothing
because that's not true
I I am a phenomenal budgeter okay play
that incredible
that tells me that you're a planner and
you're disciplined and you're consistent
about the few things in life you can
actually control
what else are you great at
um
are you good at your job
uh I I don't know people tell me I am I
don't see is everyone just conspiring to
lie lie to you they all send emails to
each other like oh God here comes Easton
let's just tell him he's great again
[Laughter]
oh that's just what I I hear in my head
too that I know that's insane but okay
so I believe it
um I don't I don't think you believe it
I think it protects you
and you and I could sit here for a long
time and probably go back to some places
where the things you were good at maybe
you're a good in choir maybe you're good
at math those are the things that kids
made fun of you about
I happen to be good at football and good
at sprinting and so those were things
everyone Hi-Fi in the guitar those are
things that high five people high-fived
my little brother was a savant at the
cello which is something that's easy to
poke at
maybe you're great at stuff that people
poked it whatever it happens to be
I think you actually believe your
co-workers I am pretty good at this
because you wouldn't stay 20 hours a day
because that's where you're getting your
uh your affirmation from
but I think you stay bubble wrapped in
this I gotta tell myself it's not that
good because I think something bad is
going to happen if I finally lean into
this thing that I'm good at then it's
gonna come crashing down they're gonna
make fun of me
and that's where I want you to begin to
seek some little wins
have you ever you've listened to the
show a lot have you kept a journal that
says five things I'm grateful for
uh not recently I used to I want you to
start a new Journal
and it's five things I love about Easton
every day
and okay I want you to tell your wife
she listens to the show too
yep cool her job is to write down three
to five things that she loves about you
and read them to you every day
listen you're gonna have to feel
somebody love you
and that feeling scares you to death
doesn't it
yes sir okay
that's the only path forward
the Nerds call it vulnerability I call
it just being a human
you are gonna have to practice learning
to hear somebody when they say you did
you did a good job I love you
I'm sorry and you go I deserved it no no
I accept your apology because you hurt
me bad bad bad
and then how serious serious are you
about changing
um
reimagining an approach to to your
physical
um well-being
um serious I want it so bad okay
I want you to do a few things okay
sure number one I just got back from San
Jose I'm spending some time with some of
the greatest guys on the planet the Mind
pump guys I want you to make that
podcast a regular listen okay
okay they are four guys from the fitness
and health industry that are changing
the conversation because the the
traditional Meathead approach is not
working
second
so my voice just crack I'm going through
puberty here second
um I want you to um hang on the line and
Jenna's gonna hook you up we're going to
give you any of their workout programs
that you want
thank you your high dollar workout
programs you can have any of them you
want
and I want you to treat them how much
like a budget you budget because it
keeps you safe you budget because you
want to make sure the 70 year old you
has food
I want you to approach working out not
as this is what this fat body deserves
that's so bad
such a wrong approach I want you to
approach it I want to be able to run and
be silly with my grandkids when I'm 70.
I'm going to start putting money in the
account now
I just I deserve to feel good when I
wake up not ugh
right I just have to feel good
and it's a weird way it's chicken or the
egg man do you start the affirmations
and start exercising you start
exercising and start feeling worthy of
the affirmations do it all at the same
time I don't care
the second is I'm or the third is I'm
gonna hook you up with my buddy Dr Lane
Norton who's another incredible resource
um for nutrition I'm gonna hook you up
with a one year of his carbon app okay
and by the way I've got no affiliation
to mind pump guys I don't make a penny
off those guys I don't make a penny from
Lane stuff okay I pay for his protein I
pay out of my own pocket for it I won't
even let him give it to me for free
um but I use a carbon at this morning I
want you to use it and it's a good way
to track nutrition and just to help you
be accountable just like you track your
expenses okay
okay
those are two of the best tools out in
the industry right now
the final thing I'm gonna tell you is
you have to
um
write letters to the five-year-old you
to the 10 year old you to the 15 year
old you
probably two to three to four pages and
I want you to be honest about what you
went through
if you have to stop and weep great but I
want you to be honest about what you
went through I want you to be honest
about who said to you and how hard it
was and maybe in your 30 year old State
you're like I wasn't that big of a deal
but it was to you back then
to own it choose reality in that moment
Own It Own It Own It Own It own it
and as you begin to begin to stand a
little taller don't be surprised if you
find yourself super angry that your wife
cheated on you you should be
that doesn't mean you go backwards but
that does mean you have to feel all the
emotions related to infidelity they're
hard and they Ripple through your life
for a long time
you don't have to believe it in this
moment in the shadows that's cool but
we're over here in the light
[Music]
I don't lie on this show
you're worth being well and you're worth
being loved my brother
thank you for the call thank you for the
call
starts today I'm going to see you in a
month
and I want you to be down the road
I'll be waiting for you we'll be right
back
hey good folks Dr John deloney here can
we all just take a minute to take a deep
breath
there's a lot going on especially in the
economy you're hearing words like
recession continued inflation thrown
around and it's making your stress
levels Spike I don't care who you are
but remember we've been through Seasons
like this before and the best thing you
can do is focus on controlling what you
can control you can control your
spending and saving you can you can
control your daily habits you can
and you can control making time for
sleep and this one is easy to forget
especially when you're stressed but
sleep is key to taking care of your
physical and mental health and I found
that the key to good sleep starts with
an incredible mattress and that's why I
love dream Cloud mattresses they're
incredibly comfortable and right now
dream cloud is making it easy to invest
in good sleep with their biggest offer
yet 40 off all mattresses plus an
additional fifty dollars in savings
exclusively for my listeners go to
dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney to get your new mattress
and start sleeping today
all right let's roll out to Minnesota
and talk to JC what's up JC
hi what's up
hey so I have a question
um my husband is a youth pastor
and that's all you need to say you want
to sit in silence for a while
um and
I have just been I mean we both have
been but
I have just been verbally abused and ver
like just attacked at churches recently
um and I just want to know like the
church where y'all attend and where he
works
yeah where he worked he just he just
finished his two weeks of uh resignation
okay
um but it was just it was just so bad
that um and we still obviously want to
do ministry because our hearts are in it
but it's just like
how do we when this is like what I think
this is like the third church that has
just hurt us so bad
um
and I guess I just want like help
knowing how to like move forward from it
all um
because it's a lot
um
yeah I don't churches can be brutal
right
yeah yeah it was um I don't know if you
want me to go into detail now I'm not
really sure how the process works but
you can't but here's the thing
um
I don't know that it's instructive I
don't know I don't I'll say it this way
it does matter what they did and what
they said I don't think it matters for
what I'm going to tell you okay okay
two things here that I want you and your
husband to spend some time reflecting on
okay
one is the common denominator
denominator the common denominator
Factor okay
okay there's a common denominator factor
that all of these were churches who have
hurt you all these were people inside of
churches that hurt you
yeah there's also a common denominator
Factor
that is y'all too
and so I think it's wise
for you both to spend some time before
you go join another Community a church
Community much less work at one
to ask yourself what are we bringing to
this equation that might be contributing
to something
that's a fair question for you to ask
similar to if somebody calls and says I
just keep getting dumped and keep
getting dumped and keep getting dumped
at some point it's not all their faults
I always want to know like what are you
bringing to this dating table well I'm
kind of like this and I kind of
and so I want you to be honest about
what y'all too individually and
collectively bring
to a church community
right you might find nothing
or you might find and you know that's
not true of course you bring stuff
but also you might
um just be around you have to be honest
that this particular Heritage this
particular Faith tradition isn't for us
anymore we've grown we're over here we
keep going to our the faith tradition
that makes us the most comfortable
expecting them to be way down the road
where we are now and we get mad that
they're not and we get mad they get mad
that we're mad who whatever the story is
you have to be honest about where you
are okay
the second thing is
Ministry does not have to be done at a
full-time church ministry can be how you
tip the waitress
Ministry can be I work at ubereats and
he works at a print shop and we honor
and love everybody especially the least
of these
that's Ministry too
right and unfortunately
churches don't have
um some of the same protections that um
you can't say certain things in a
workplace you can't just demean people
in a workplace
right or you can't say I'm praying for
you because and then spill a bunch of
you know gossip and whatever poison on
you
right and so it might be time to say
okay we're gonna we're still gonna do
ministry quote unquote we're still going
to be
people who espouse our faith values to
everyone all over the place
but we're gonna do it in a business
we're gonna do it as a small business
we're gonna do it cutting grass
and we're gonna do it as counselors
we're going to do it in a chain here's
I'm saying change your picture of what
of what your core vision for your life
is change the environment change the
picture of that and at least spend time
entertaining it might not be where you
land but at least spend time
entertaining it because right now you
keep sticking your hand back in the bag
and getting bit by the same rattlesnake
and you're so mad at the rattlesnake and
it's just looking at you going that's
what I do I bite people like you
yeah
so give me an example of of a thing a
church did
charge my husband just left I was
I was an office manager there and the
church just let this one guy
who wasn't even on staff just um
he just let that let this man like uh
call our the current past at that time
we've gone through two Pastors in like
six months
but let him just totally attack them uh
personally verbally abusing um
um just yelling at them
it's this guy who's been with the church
for like 20 plus years
and then he uh
I'm the type of person who I like to
follow the rules I see things as black
and white nerd just kidding he's still
kidding okay he kept trying to like not
follow the rules in the office and
everybody else has to and I was the only
one to like stand up to him and say hey
like I'm creating these processes for a
reason me to follow these and then I
became a Target and then he him and his
friend of the church who they both
had some sort of leadership they weren't
paid called me a Nazi they called me
weak they called me pathetic they told
me and my co-worker to shut up
um and the church
didn't do anything about it I wrote
two letters
to the you know the leadership team
about it didn't hear anything or current
pastor at the time ended up leaving my
husband
it was hard he was in a really hard spot
because he like loved his youth group
and wanted to keep working there
he was in a very easy spot
if people in a work environment where me
and my wife are both employed if
somebody's treating my wife like that
that doesn't end well for anybody
yeah and I will as Jesus says I'ma dust
my sandals off and as the great Jay-Z
says I'm gonna brush my shoulders off
I'm out bye Felicia we go
yeah
you see what I'm saying
and like it's it's a
it's shameful and by the way that is
happening at churches all across the
country it's happening in elementary
schools and at school board meetings one
or two or three absolutely power starved
maniacal idiots is ruining it for
everybody and until institutions like
churches like schools like universities
stand up and say get out
what's going to happen is they're going
to drive out every young passionate
person
who is interested in caring about people
loving young people loving old people
loving everybody whether it's through an
education whether it's through Public
Service whether it's through their faith
tradition they're going to run them out
because their leadership is cowards
cowards
and I'm sorry that happened to you
yeah and they the church under the they
got a different interim pastor hold on
hold on hold on
you keep wanting to talk about your
ex-boyfriend
you're married now oh you're married now
you you wanna you used to date somebody
and you keep going to Facebook to see
who they're with even though you're
married
yeah and then you heard you had a kid
and you want to find out what his kid
looked like
because at one point a long time ago you
imagined yourself having kids with him
and I'll tell you I I I wouldn't give
that church another thought
and they've showed you what they think
of you they've shown you what they think
of love and accountability and Justice
and doing right by people
yeah and they've shown their cowardice
by hiding behind two loudmouth morons
who probably have nice checkbooks
yeah or like to wield scripture like um
like a like us
like a sword
instead of like a
manual like a like a
narrative operating guide for how to
love the least of these
yeah it says widows and orphans and
hungry people not you Nazi right
yeah so dude if you went to a grocery
store and every time you walked in
they're like ah here comes the Nazi
witch ah and they threw fruit at you you
would just leave and you're like they're
nuts right
I want you to treat this situation the
same
and maybe this is the time and I've get
I'm I'm just picking this out of the
Moon don't overthink this okay but maybe
this is the time when you rethink sit
down and ask your husband husband I
won't bite your head off I'll be honest
I mean I'll
I will I I just need some honest truth
am I too overbearing about rules do I
hide do they protect me do I hide do I
hang on to them too tightly and he might
go in a flinching way yeah right maybe
this is that season
and maybe you tell them hey you hung on
at that church too long you broke my
heart for a while you chose the youth
group over me
yeah and you need to deal with that in
your marriage and it's real easy when
you get that Crossways that you're gonna
blame the church you're gonna get mad at
these guys but really that's just that's
just misdirected anger you're really mad
at your husband you're heartbroken
did he ever confront that guy that was
coming by the office and causing all the
problems
start there
there is no but
you start there
he he did confront the church nope nope
okay
if a man walks into the place where me
and my wife both work
and he sends my wife out in tears
because he was calling her names just
for her doing her job
he'll deal directly with me
and I'm not saying that in some Beefcake
Flex off I'm not talking about we're
gonna do a pose down I'm gonna fight him
in a church parking lot what I'm saying
is I'm gonna go have that conversation
and your husband didn't do that and
there's part of you inside wondering are
am I worth am I worth rescuing
and you got to start there leave the
church out of this stuff there's idiots
everywhere every organization on the
planet has extraordinary wonderful
people and idiots
and occasionally the idiots run the
place I also know by the way there's
some really extraordinary churches out
there doing amazing things
right okay but the question you have to
ask is husband why
why
when I looked over my shoulder why
weren't you standing there
when this guy was in there yelling when
this him and his knuckleheaded buddy
were in there hollering at me and saying
these things about me
why weren't you at their front door of
their homes
aren't you on the phone with them
am I worth so little
that's where you start that's a that's
that's a
girl with a broken heart
and you're not crazy and you're not
you're not misguided and I'm not overly
zealous
sorry this happened
sorry it happened
for many of us
I am including myself here
it's very hard
to wind up
occupation work the HR part of
employment
and my faith and my faith Journey
and my love of teaching
my love of helping hurting people
and people who throw grenades just
because that gives them the only little
like shred of power they have in their
miserable tiny little lives
hard and so
professional Ministry is not for
everybody
just not and that's all right
Formula One racing isn't for everybody
janitorial services isn't for everybody
only a select few who can do Excellence
when nobody's watching
this is you and your husband go on a
quick weekend retreat you'll ask each
other you ask yourselves
what do we bring to this
where were you hon where were you
and give him permission to speak into
you because I'm sure he's got some
thoughts on you too
and then ask yourselves what does
Ministry look like for us not in a
church
what does employment look like for us
somewhere not in a church and at least
just sit with that for a while it might
not be where you land but at least sit
with it
because right now this is one two Church
three
there's a pattern like quickly emerging
and when we see trend lines when we see
patterns often let's just stop what
we're doing right now so the pattern
doesn't get the trend doesn't get any
any worse maybe we do something
completely different and see if that
reverses the trend
so sorry this happened to you JC
institutions churches colleges
elementary schools
school boards
if you do not immediately start standing
up to the idiots
on each side of the aisle on each side
of on on every side of the social
economic scale if you don't start
standing up to the few loud lunatics
You're Gonna Lose everybody
[Music]
they're just going to take their ball
and go home
we'll be right back
hey what's up deloney here listen you
and me and everybody else on the planet
has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful non-anxious
life get your copy today at John
deloney.com store that's John
deloney.com store
all right we're back as we wrap up
today's show
we're gonna do an am I the problem is it
me go for it Kelly so this is a reminder
send these in put in the subject line or
in the email am I the problem keep them
short and we want people to respond how
if they think this person's the problem
put it in Social or in the reviews for
the show there we go all right let's do
it hi John my boyfriend and I recently
broke up after 10 months together he's
60 and never been married I'm 48
divorced and was married for 15 years
my question has to do with him having a
really close relationship with his best
friend's wife hey oh when we were first
together they called and texted all day
every day and I just heard that lately
her husband sleeps on the couch
also when we would go out together as
couples with his other friends and their
wives he would get real flirtatious with
the women and ignore everyone else at
the table this really hurt me I don't
feel like it was overreacting but he
thinks it was I just need to know if
this is normal acceptable behavior
just as you describe it it just oops me
out you know why because we all know
that guy
we all know that guy no it's gross it's
just gross the only thing I would say is
it's on her is
um
I don't know I would work hard to walk
down the road why does this hurt me
versus ugh you're gross I'm out and it
may be that this guy's pretty special
he's obviously pretty flirtatious and
pretty uh
like shimuzi
um and maybe just feel felt good to have
someone say I love you charming yeah
that's probably I call it schmoozy you
might call it he's Charming well I
understand that you know where you you
feel special because they talk to you
like you're the only person in the world
that's it and there's always that guy
that's like oh your husband never says
things like this and you're like no he
doesn't
ew it's just ooh
just ooh so no you're you you dodged you
dodged a bullet like the Matrix on this
one good for you gross on a stick
anybody
just went in the show on that one Kelly
gosh next time we're gonna end the show
by looking at each other's vomit that's
how we're gonna end that
gross that's gross this guy's gross just
I can just see the six-year-old yeah
he's just
run run for the Hills
as the great Iron Maiden once sang love
you guys stay in school bye
[Music]
foreign